there are teams of physicists around the
world pushing the envelope of quantum
mechanics coming up with wondrous
inventions and I just want to finish up
here with one of those inventions so I'd
like to bring in what is known as
quantum levitation you will only know of
this if you are a YouTube junkie because
it's having its first public
demonstration in the United States here
at the World Science Festival let me
bring in one of the inventors of this
demonstration dr. boas Almog who's
coming to us
from Tel Aviv University the super
conductivity group with Professor
deutscher and what Baz is going to do
here he has a disk which he's had in
liquid nitrogen over here makes it very
cold and when that disk gets very cold
it becomes a super conductor when you
apply quantum mechanics to a
superconductor in the vicinity of a
magnet it says that the magnetic lines
of force get quantized into little tubes
little tentacles that grab hold of that
superconducting just look at that it's
sitting there in a stable position even
if he turns this thing upside down
it's just locked into place can you
change the angle on that guy's sitting
up top look at that it just floats there
in midair now this magnet over here is a
circular magnet so that has a constant
flux around the circumference and now
you can spin the object and again it's
just locked into place by these quantum
threads these quantum tentacles and if
you now takes this and put this on this
circular track there's now a magnetic
track in the shape of a circle and again
that flux is constant along the track so
if you let this go
is that amazing or what
so now if he he can actually take this
tract flip it upside down and he can
have this little disc actually hover
underneath the track again the track is
just gripping it with these quantum
tentacles so let's see if that one goes
look at it just hovering underneath sort
of like a little flying saucer as it
goes around